Yeah,
no,
I want to come back also to what you
were saying about the predictive power
of Iq and conscientiousness,
which I don't dispute that I'm also not
one of these people who suffers under
the delusion that these things are
totally open quotes,
socially determined,
closed quotes.
I mean,
I understand and believe that they have
high heritability and identifiable
genetic sources in that variability and
so on.
But you know,
the standard old joke used to be,
you can tell because you don't worry
about personality psychology that I do
at the standard old junk used to be that
everything,
everything's 50 percent heritable,
that,
that pretty much anything that you could
measure as a trait that has any
stability within the lifetime also turns
out to have a heritability somewhere to
your point five.
But there's the other point five of,
you know,
some people have low iqs because they
were exposed to too much.
They see,
you know,
um,
I believe that conscientiousness,
this can probably be like,
I believe you suggested earlier that we
know something about this already about
developmental determinative of shifts in
conscientious.
And uh,
so,
you know,
we have to caution ourselves against
talking about these individual
difference factors as if they are a
beautiful attributes of individuals that
are going to undermine Eddie,
sort of progressive improvement of,
of circumstances for people are,
are,
are going to create bad byproducts of
attempts to produce social justice.
It's just gonna you know,
you're going to leave your country and
just people out there being parasites or
something
there,
there is of course decent evidence that
there's cultural effects on Iq,
I mean the flynn effect,
which is named after the man who,
who described the,
the,
the phenomena indicates that the average
Iq has been increasing quite
substantially over the last hundred
years.
And the reason for that,
no one knows for sure,
but one of the putative reasons for that
is that we've lifted the bottom out of
catastrophe.
So there aren't people whose Iq is,
are stunted by,
by exposure to zero information during
critical developmental periods and who
didn't get enough to eat.
Yes.
I was going to say superior about
nutrition.
Everybody probation.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
So we've,
we've wiped out in many ways,
we've wiped out the worst effects of
privation and that's increasingly true
as well on,
on the worldwide scale worldwide stage,
you know there's about 150,000
people a day right now being lifted out
of absolute poverty by UN standards,
the fastest improvement in the history
of the world by a huge margin and also
about 300,000
people a day being hooked up to the
electrical grid.
So we are making some progress,
removing the absolute privation problem,
which is a nontrivial problem.
The problem with most of the attempts to
raise Iq is that they don't change the
variance in Iq.
They tend to raise the average Iq across
the population and that leaves the
inequality of Iq inequality problem
basically untouched.
So there have been studies trying to
estimate how much socioeconomic
pressure,
let's say you have to place on an
individual to raise their iq lowering.
It's easy,
right?
Because making something worse is always
easier than making something better.
But if I remember correctly,
if you take a,
an identical twin who's adopted out at
birth in order to produce a 15 point
increase in Iq compared to the other
twin,
which is a one standard deviation
increase and about the same as the
average difference between a university
student in a,
in an average state college and an
average high school student,
you have to move the one twin from the
fifth percentile of socioeconomic status
to the 95th percentile.
So you need about a three standard
deviation improvement and socioeconomic
conditions to produce a one standard
deviation improvement in Icu.
So it looks like it can be done,
but it's.
But it's expensive,
you know,
and
I see,
I see what you're saying.
I'm kind of surprised I'm actually,
I've been given,
you know,
we just mentioned malnutrition as one
possible source of low Iq.
What possible developmental source.
I'm Kinda surprised that,
uh,
to the degree that the flit effect might
be due to things like,
or reduction of the number of people
exposed to severe malnutrition,
that it wouldn't have also
simultaneously truncated the variance a
little bit.
That seems like they said,
well,
sorry,
let me restate that.
It has truncated.
It has truncated the variance,
although the data on that isn't clear
isn't as clear,
but so,
but,
but I,
I do believe that it's a reasonable
inference to make that the variance has
been truncated.
It's also hidden to some degree because
the Iq tests are always renewed them to
keep the variance out of standard 15
points so.
So it makes it difficult to look
retrospectively and see what's happened
to the variance.
So by the time,
the other problem too is that,
you know,
you get these stories now and then about
these companies that come out with the
claims that their brain exercises can
improve Iq and the literature on that is
damn dismal.
I can tell you it's that the holy grail
is to produce cognitive exercises that
produce a legitimate impact on fluid
intelligence and,
and like there's been a lot of work done
on that and the answer is so far is that
it doesn't work.
What about,
what about like video gaming?
I mean,
I know there has been this suggestion
that playing video games actually
improves at least some aspects of
intelligence.
There's a couple of studies that
indicated that video games might improve
spatial intelligence,
but,
but here's
problem and I think this is,
this is a critical problem or perhaps an
insoluble one or at least no one's
solved is that what you get is that if
you are,
if you exercise yourself substantially
on a given game,
you can radically accelerate your
performance in the game so you can get
much better at those specific skill
share,
but you don't get generalization across
cognitive sets,
which is what you're really hoping for.
Because I thought,
I thought that was the claim for some.
They have shown some increases in
spatial Iq,
but there's not very many studies.
And I would say they're far overbalanced
by the other side of the research
equation,
which continually says,
and I've looked at this because I'm
really interested in the improvement of
ICU.
I mean,
that's,
that's the holy grail in some sense.
And that,
and,
uh,
the,
the overwhelming preponderance of
evidence suggests that you don't get
generalization outside the narrow
domain.
Now why that is,
and even this,
it's even worse say because you might
say,
well,
imagine that you could take five
different domains of intelligence still
associated type with,
with Jay,
and you had people practice routines in
all five dimensions.
Maybe you'd get generalization under
those circumstances.
And the,
the,
the results of the research attempting
that indicate that no,
as soon as you move away from those
specific practice instances,
you don't get generalization.